in part one we followed her oh hinge of
family forced to flee their village in
Myanmar when government soldiers and
vigilantes went on a deadly rampage the
shahbazi master was with you and will
use all of our bodies will become a fan
I bother nearly Monica they are in part
two we pick up with the family as they
struggle to adapt to refugee life then
meets some of the row hinge a militants
who triggered the crisis
[Music]
due to Mia and his family ran for their
lives when Buddhist vigilantes attacked
their farming village
[Music]
five days after fleeing on foot and by
bug they're safe in Bangladesh
the children are vaccinated for polio
and measles
[Music]
then everyone climbs into a truck headed
to the main refugee camps
[Music]
three hours later the family has dropped
off on the side of the road free meal is
served and they're on their own the
address of a relative who escaped an
earlier round to violence is all they
have Zach Olivia
would you marry reliable already
beautiful a maternity load not even
about silly Sally Laguna Rosales on a
marambra row at hour a day in the weeks
since Roe hinge a insurgent group Arzo
attacked government forces and ignited
this crisis the militants have declared
a truce and gone quiet it's no secret
that many who survived now live among
the refugees we're just off the main
road that runs through the camps and
there are two military checkpoints here
and here we're about to go speak with
two are some members who were involved
in the August 25 attacks when everybody
ready yeah about that she said Cara
would not I'd you elaborate a zoo room
fault I could never you know digital era
doesn't money so DRI he not good you
reminded bully money marina very own
automatically autonomous omaha more in
our hand whoever does not activity dump
the money KD the whole illuminate throw
George I would even are uneasy owner
Mohammed was shot twice as he ran from
the military counter-attack
safe Ulla lost part of his hand to a
rocket-propelled grenade lost until you
know the era heilige Galina kuna yala
norsu officer in hiding agreed to speak
with us about what went wrong
- pom pom harem mother for Hassan Hassan
ie cousin has a million and where Evelyn
is a hop level Odyssey for in Hassan
Hassan does a hundred thousand people
Televisa landed on collision imminent
Farah to finally call failure and
digital this is telling the - hallelujah
but does green avarage the new Marie
Janna la da say Wendy does Jamaat even
Madeleine middle I'm mr. top-level
Oliviero John O'Malley the salami movie
how did the attack backfires so
catastrophically no they didn't act a
ceviche I rather didn't do her yeah
actually shaving for you pass out of the
Santa Anna Yano ever point what a lame-o
Aldo Leona leaky buddy mark that ladder
we will decimate our Abhishek Williger
uber will America ramadasa Baghdad -
when I tal ki ng the candelabra
not a more human gorilla side our Tara
does it be she got a bridle on Gemma to
be similar there are thousands of ring
you have been killed more than a
half-million a flood the country do you
feel any personal responsibility for
what happened under son Adam was a
generic on the Rihanna's area are a
loose a medium boozy dianthus a teeny
arid the high beloved in a boozer
Arabella
our Colonel Holland muscle man handle a
celebrity on dinner
a lot of the row hanging I really hate
Parsa because they feel like they
provoked this this catastrophic on
people most of whom have nothing to do
with arson who are simple villagers
trying to survive in what was already a
desperate situation for them but I think
it's really important for the world to
understand that this is not a war this
is not a conflict between militants and
the army this is an army campaign
against civilians against villagers who
are unarmed who are not fighting back in
any way driving along the border one
afternoon we see fresh smoke across the
river in Myanmar
so this river behind me separates
Bangladesh from Myanmar five weeks after
Myanmar me began their crackdown there's
still village fires being set in the
distance we just saw a helicopter
circulating above one about three
kilometers in that direction
in the days after thousands more
refugees streamed into Bangladesh
due to MIA and his family are lucky to
be alive but the daily grind of
surviving in a foreign land is setting
in sorry BJ Tata Havana for horrible
horror and Gora Gora
BGR
[Music]
at a nearby health clinic the family has
given some basic medicine now they must
find a better shelter you did add a hot
toddy they don't know no mucho or if you
were a hot area or omelet I know Pelican
has a vegan
Godzilla's our module together we now
have a super camp which is being created
completely unplanned people are building
their own huts wherever they find space
and it's a catastrophic because as soon
as a typhoon hits this camp or an
epidemic like cholera hits this camp
people are gonna die in massive numbers
are you concerned that given how
desperate the conditions are here and
have been that this could breed
radicalism in the long term we should be
concerned by this population which feels
completely abandoned by the world you
see a lot of mullahs arriving here from
all over the world we've seen them
coming from Saudi and Australia and
turkey really grips with a radical
agenda who are trying to push these
people into taking a more radical stance
if the mainstream world doesn't take up
the plight of the Rohingya people
radicals and extremists will exploit
their private plight and they will say
look nobody cares about you we're the
only ones who can really help you before
leaving we return to the makeshift camp
where we met firuze the ten-year-old
orphan but he's gone
overnight the Bangladesh military raised
his camp to force new arrivals into
existing camps unwanted at home and
vulnerable in exile the plight of the
row hinges no end
that was part two of the unwanted also
be sure to check out a virtual reality
documentary under anger crisis about
and please subscribe to aj+ for more
documentaries like this
you